not all jokes are created equal and some
come with a price tag to proof it
in the american version of the office
the pricey gag occurred during a season
3 episode entitled the benihana
christmas
fans will no doubt remember the show's
consistent quality when it comes to
christmas specials and for a lot of
people the benihana episode tends to
rank among the best
this holiday romp opens with carol
stills showing up at michael scott's
office to dump him just before the
holiday party
while there are many good reasons we can
think of to break up with season 3
michael scott
the last draw for carol is a doctor
christmas card created by mr scott in
which he spliced his own head on top of
an image of carol's ex-husband from an
old ski trip she took with her family
what you didn't realize at the time was
that i was with you
in a sense i was in your heart and next
to your kids
what this is so weird
this setback sets up the drama of the
episode michael is now stuck with two
tickets to sandals jamaica and no one to
enjoy the trip with
on top of that he has to show his face
at his office christmas party without a
date
office suck up andy bernard decides to
take the heartbroken michael on a boys
outing to benihana to help him forget
about carol with dwight and jim and toe
they head out to an awkward and boozy
hibachi lunch that actually results in
them picking up two young waitresses
michael and andy bring their new
girlfriends back to the office christmas
party and hilarity ensues
memorably michael has to make a mark on
his girlfriend's arm with a sharpie so
he can remember which one is his
although a nice hibachi dinner can
certainly start to add up especially
if you order too many of those onion
volcanoes it wasn't the food that pushed
the comedy bill into five figure
territory on this one
while the use of benihana's corporate
trademarks came cheap a different
intellectual property issue required nbc
to pay the piper
on a recent episode of the office ladies
podcast a delightful bit of weekly fan
service hosted by jenna fisher who
played pam and angela kingsley who
played angela
former staff writer jen salada stopped
by to spill the beans on the expensive
gag
according to salata the joke that
ultimately had nbc reaching deep into
its corporate pockets was a four second
gag where michael sings a couple of bars
of two tickets to paradise by any money
to relish his upcoming vacation to a
sandals resort in jamaica
i've got two tickets to paradise
pack your bags we're leaving after
tomorrow
in her appearance on the office ladies
podcast saletta said that the short joke
came with a large price tag
she was informed of this fun fact after
the fact by producer kent zabornak
at the sound mix i found out from kent
that that was a sixty thousand dollar
joke none of my jokes i've ever written
have been the sixty thousand dollar joke
saletta wasn't sure but she told the
podcast that she recalled the show's
music budget being reduced not too long
after the episode
leading her to believe that her little
joke may have had a way bigger impact
than she'd anticipated
the process of song clearance is a
notorious pain in the entertainment
business
and it can easily wreck a show where
movie's production budget is costs get
out of control
what's your funding two hundred dollars
what's ours again
um 201 right in order to clear a song
lawyers representing the network
in this case nbc have to work with the
music label that holds the publishing
rights for a song that's featured during
an episode
no matter how small or incidental the
feature in this case eddie money's
publisher columbia records made sixty
thousand dollars off of michael's brief
cover performance
not too shabby for four seconds worth of
someone else's work
as an interesting aside a benihana
christmas had another issue with song
clearance
one scene from the episode features an
office performance of john mayer's
saccharine love song your body is a
wonderland
office star bj novak who plays ryan the
temp is actually friends with mayor
in real life and was able to negotiate a
pretty reasonable settlement after
overcoming some initial apprehension
the cost of mayor song one personalized
dundy award statue for tallest music
dude
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one